- We're back,
with my nearest and dearest,
Cameron Diaz and Lucy Liu.
So we grew, and we grew
up, and now we are moms.
Do you think you're a
different person now, Lucy,
than you were then?
Like, aside from us knowing
each other and our friendship,
just you as a human?
- I think in my twenties,
I felt very bulletproof
and very, you know,
I don't wanna say it was risk-taking
'cause it was beyond that.
It was like, I didn't really
care if I lived or died,
you know, I just didn't and I
lost my father a few years ago
and I didn't really recognize the levels
that we have in our lives.
And you know, like he was a place in my,
in my life that was always sort of a,
kind of a roof, you know?
And so suddenly you feel like
the roof has been torn off
and then you sort of recognize,
"Oh, you know, I am now the roof."
You know, and I happen to have a child,
so I guess I'm the roof to that child.
So now I really have to understand
that I have to shelter
him and I have to show,
I have a responsibility and it's,
it's a very powerful thing,
it's also terrifying.
If I think about it, I think
my heart was smaller back then,
'cause it was sort of more
inclined to what I wanted to do,
but now it's sort of like,
what do we want to do?
And it feels, it feels good because I feel
like a fuller person.
Like life seems a much more, you know,
kind of colorful and wild
because there's so many more
opportunities, as a mom,
to kind of like discover and, you know,
there's so much more curiosity with kids.
And it's sort of, it's mind blowing,
and it's actually more
terrifying in a way, you know,
because you're also responsible
for this little person.
- Highest stakes.
- So it's like, oh my God,
I thought I was on a ride
back then, a wild ride,
but actually it's now that
it's even more intense.
- Well you nailed it,
because you're just dealing
with your own mortality
and all of the sudden
when you have a kid, I don't
care if it sounds codependent,
my kids are more meaningful
to me than my own life.
- I think there's
something that, in our DNA,
that gets triggered, you know,
like that just clicks on
when you become a parent.
You have to make sure that they survive.
They have to, they go on.
You, we will die.
I'm sorry to get like morbid,
and this is those times when Drew goes,
(sighs) "Really you're gonna die?
Do we have to talk about that?"
(laughs) But, like.
- For your first show
it's all about mortality.
- I know.
(Cameron and Lucy laughing)
I think I'm ready to talk about death.
- CBS is like, "Wait a minute."
- I think I'm no longer a young idiot
who thinks I am immortal,
which I'm glad to know I'm
not, I wasn't the only one.
I mean, I hurled myself around,
I abused this carcass to no end.
And I just thought, true,
I was gonna die young,
so who cares?
Live now and go for it.
And now, yeah, I mean,
2020 will make you think
about your mortality,
children will make you
think about your mortality.
- You know, my twenties,
it was just sort of like,
"Here we go, yeah, all right.
Yep, jump on that?
Gotcha.
Oh, is that a wild horse?
Oh cool. Yeah, no, I know
how to hold on for my life.
Let's go." (laughs)
You know?
- There's such a liberation
in that too though, you know?
- Yeah, I'm so glad I did it all.
- When I thought about
trying to accomplish
something big in my life at another point,
you two were the people I did it with.
And so of course, what a natural fit
that you're the two people
that came into my head
and my heart when I thought,
how would I like to honor this endeavor?
I see myself with you guys.
- Exactly what the world needs.
They need your light, they
need your joyous-ness,
they need your perspective.
One of the things that I have always
been in total awe of in you
is your ability to take
in all the information,
how quick you are to not just,
like, what's in front of you,
but the nuances and the sort
of the humanity and intellect.
You can, you read more books
than any person I know,
you listen to more music,
you look at more art.
You bring, you watch
more television and film.
You're actually taking
in all the information
and you're synthesizing it.
And you're bringing it into
this really unique perspective
that is all about how it
connects all of us together,
even if it doesn't feel
like it has anything
to do with one another
and you bring it to the world
in this joyous, beautiful,
like buoyant light, that is you.
And you, it's a gift.
It's like truly a gift
that you give the world.
And you're gonna make the world a happier,
better place by giving us that gift.
- You have a big soul and a big heart
and doing this show is
really special and wonderful
because you have something to share
and you have gone through
tough times in your life.
You've had issues with your family,
you've had issues with, you
know, like marriages, divorces.
You have something to share.
And I don't know that I can
say that about a lot of things.
I've never been married,
I've never been divorced.
I haven't done a lot of
the things that you have.
So, to me, the experience that you have
and that you have to share is exciting.
And I think that you
should feel free to do that
because that's who you are.
You're a very open, generous person.
- I asked you guys here so
I could honor you today.
(Lucy laughs)
That's what this was about for me.
- Well.
- Yeah, but you can't honor us
without us honoring you.
This is the symbiotic relationship
and you have to be able to give and take
and understand that, a lot of times
when I give a friend a
compliment, they can't take it.
You know?
And like, it's time for us to receive.
- Well, as you said at one of my weddings,
(Lucy and Cameron laughing)
when you read the E. E. Cummings poem,
"I Carry Your Heart in my Heart,"
and I carry both of you in my heart.
I always have, I always will.
Thank you.
- [Cameron] Thank you, no thank you.
(all laughing)
- And thank you.
And thank you.
Listen, man.
I'm gonna be thinking tonight in my bed,
wondering how I got so lucky
to, like, live a life with you guys.
Thank you more than words can ever say.
- Can't wait to see
the rest of the season.
(audience applauding)
- We're gonna celebrate a lot
of things here on this show,
and friendship is certainly one of them.
(upbeat music)